vous êtes dans la nouvelle série de la
maison de prime vidéo lol qui rira le
dernier l'objectif c'est de faire rire
son suivant c'est comment l'expérience
sur réelle on parle de télé-réalité là
c'est de la télé surréalité
un gros laboratoire où tu dois agir et
réagir complètement à l'encontre de tes
codes répétez après moi touche
[Musique]
mh8os
et toi ne pas rire ne pas sourire alors
que d'habitude moi j'ai tendance à faire
des personnages ou faire de l'humour qui
est un peu
tu peux pas aller là donc ça a été une
grande souffrance mais ma satisfaction
c'est que ça reste une souffrance qui
provoque le rire des téléspectateurs en
tout cas Patrick
professionnel depuis bientôt 40 ans au
début du premier épisode vous dites
professionnels derrière chaque blague il
faut vérité
mais moi
de satellite qui gravite j'ai pas le
gars qui va revirer la place à l'envers
je suis juste content d'être encore dans
la dans la Voie Lactée en quelque part
parmi les planètes j'ai pas une étoile
puis un petit astre
qui continue à revenir de façon cyclique
à toutes les 400 heures
je les anniversaires d'herbeo Saint Jean
de Bosco le verbe feindre à la première
personne du singulier du subjonctif
mon enfance ça c'est clair
ça a donné ça c'est ça que ça donne des
enfants éduqués à carbo les
suppositoires de Satan les supposons
[Musique]
j'ai adoré votre autobiographie
déboussolée vraiment là c'était sur
le paradoxe c'est que il fait Pelletier
et quand même quelqu'un d'assez gêné qui
a perdu sa virginité sur le tard
exactement mais pourtant vous étiez à
peu près toujours tout nu dans rb-o sur
scène avec enchaîné et tout ça comment
vous expliquer ça un tel contraste le
dégoût
psychopathe non non mais d'ailleurs
c'est ça j'étais assez franc dans les
années 80 je sais que correspondre
peut-être à un modèle je savais pas
exactement qui j'étais je ne sais pas
encore aujourd'hui mais je suis un petit
peu plus et donc
voilà donc j'ai fait partie d'un groupe
complètement irrévérencieux alors que
j'étais quelqu'un de très timide et un
grand romantique idéaliste
vraiment vraiment
c'est quand j'ai écouté lol qui rira le
dernier je me disais mon Dieu avec ce
qui se passe en ce moment les gens ont
l'impression de s'auto-senstruel RBO
pourrait pas exister en 2022
pour exister mais
rb-offrait des gags à propos de ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui dans le contexte
qui est aujourd'hui
je connais des humoristes présentement
des jeunes humoristes qui sont beaucoup
plus acides que ce qu'on était c'est
juste qu'on les voit pas à Radio-Canada
on les voit pas tva enlève sur le même
sur le web faut savoir c'est surtout sur
scène
dans des roses battles j'ai entendu des
affaires Louis-Philippe là
non non
personne qu'on s'entende il se manque
pas là c'est juste c'est les sujets
qu'est-ce qu'on vous souhaite pour 2023
un nouveau film un nouveau spectacle un
nouveau livre ou un nouveau documentaire
un spectacle solo de Louis-Philippe
willemette moi c'est ce qui ferait mon
plus grand bonheur en 2023 je pense ça
te
démangeais
il vous reste juste 16 dollars sur votre
chèque je vous donne ça en deux pieds